all right so I was recording a code
review and I did the thing that I do
sometimes which is giving advice that is
just generally helpful to everything not
just that particular code review so in
this video we're going to go over why
includes sometimes give you errors like
when you use hash included in C plus
we'll take like a deeper look at how it
works in the first place and how we can
you know make sure that it works because
I remember this was something that like
I used to struggle with when I was a
beginner as well so hopefully this is
going to be helpful to you guys and the
rest of this code review which by the
way is a Pac-Man game will come out
later this week I think this is a super
common error
um and that is I typed in hash include
uh I put in my file name and it can't
find it why is everything so difficult
in C plus plus so let's actually talk
about this so first and foremost in C
sharp we have something called using and
then we usually specify some sort of
namespace so like you know you'd write
something like using system and then in
Java we have a similar thing but kind of
with packages and if you kind of import
like system for example as a package
then all the classes are kind of of
available to you here and the same we're
like using in C sharp that's because
those languages are a little bit more
advanced in the sense that every like I
guess like symbol so like classes like
functions or variables whatever they
kind of exist within a namespace and
that namespace like the compiler's aware
of that itself kind of like internally
it just knows that okay there's a class
called like you know timer I know that
that exists it exists in this particular
like namespace so therefore if that
namespace is a play and it's in the same
kind of module then of course I can just
find that and assuming that like the
visibility checks out meaning I have
kind of access to it then it is done
that job's done C plus a little bit more
primitive when you type in hash include
what it is doing is it is looking up
this file from a particular file path
which is actually what you've specified
this is actually a file path and then
it's just pasting in the contents so
what we kind of want it to do is take
this and like do that because you can
see that if I just paste that in right
now it actually fixes all the errors
like we still need to know what sdl is
but other than that it fixes all of the
errors like all of the kind of timer
class related errors so that's what
we're trying to do it's just that
obviously we don't want to go around
pasting this in every kind of file every
CPP file that uses this timer class
because that would be really really
annoying if we then decided to actually
add another function or rename something
we'd have to go through all the files
manually and do that so instead we take
advantage of the preprocessor which is
capable of just including it from a
single Source that's kind of the benefit
and so because it this is a file path
you can't just like you know be like you
know import timer or using timer or
whatever you actually have to make sure
that the compiler knows how to find this
file now I do have a video about header
files I'm pretty sure I hopefully talk
about this there but I'll have it linked
up there it's quite an old video but it
should still be like real relevant and
helpful but basically what will happen
is there's two different ways of kind of
including files you have these angular
brackets and then you have these quotes
now quotes actually do the same thing as
angular brackets plus more so this is
actually a little bit more restrictive
because what this will do what these
quotes will do is first and foremost
they will try and evaluate the path that
you've typed in here now I say path
because of course it could be something
like this you know like that could be a
director like it is a full path I just
happen to have the file name here alone
but what it will do is it will first try
and evaluate this path relative to the
location of this actual file and then if
it doesn't find it there it will look at
the compiler include directories meaning
that inside our project settings we have
inside CC plus sales General we have
like additional include directories
specified here and these I mean there's
another place you can put it you can go
V6 C plus plus directories and then put
it into uh like include directories
external include directories it's all
kind of the same thing but the point is
you're telling the compiler hey this is
a director three so you can look there
and of course the compiler like this is
msvc Visual Studio it will have its own
kind of Library include directories
which is how things like uh you know a c
math string you know all of these kind
of uh you know C plus plus header files
that are part of the library that's how
they work they're the same as any other
file like if I right click on cmath and
go to document here
um if I look at where this is like this
is
located you know in C program files
Microsoft Visual Studio 2022 blah blah
in msvc inside this kind of version and
then include and then cmath right so
it's a header that's actually located
kind of in the C plus plus library that
belongs to the compiler we're using to
build this project that's where it comes
from and it's able to access it just
because that directory where it's
located is kind of known to the compiler
and if you use well either of these kind
of styles it will kind of go to that
compiler include directory so what we've
learned here is this will do first it
will do kind of relative and then it
will do the compiler right whereas this
just does the compiler and that's it so
hopefully that kind of clears it up a
little bit now that we know that
hopefully the reason why this is an
error should be really really easy to
debug it's clearly the fact that this
file is not located in the same
directory as this file so we know where
timer.cvp is because we can hover our
Mouse over it and it will tell us that
it's in Pac-Man timer.cbp
now if we hover our Mouse over this it's
in headers timer.cbp right so there it's
in a different directory and the reason
why this happened is because I just made
the file through Visual Studio here and
clearly like I mean it just put it into
Pac-Man and I didn't really bother like
making sure it was in the right
directory or whatever it just wound up
in two different directories you can
also just right click on this and go to
open containing folder uh you can just
see where the file is right and if you
do the same thing with like this guy
then you well you can see that they're
obviously like in two different
directories This Guy's in codery Pac-Man
this one's in the code review Pac-Man
headers
so how do we fix this now another really
easy way to see this is if you go to
Pac-Man over here in visual Studios just
full on Visual Studio tutorial
um we have this channel files button
very very very important because what
you're seeing here is not a real
directory structure these are called
filters and what they are like you can
make filters
like LOL he has a filter yeah this is
not a folder on disk it's just like a
filter kind of like a group of files if
you will that's actually stored inside
this pacman.vcx project.filters file
right so that's kind of what contains
that in fact if we look at this let's
just open in wordpad open wordpad that's
funny
um you can see that like we have these
kind of here's a filter called header
files and this is kind of like this this
is like the actual file and this is like
the filter that is kind of under right
so um that's kind of all it really is so
what you need to do is make sure that if
you actually want to see the directory
structure and see all of these files as
they appear and the critical thing here
is that these filters yeah
obviously this doesn't care about them
because this is based on actual physical
files that you're including so what I
see often as well is people will try and
match this up they'll be like okay well
I'm in the source directory so let me go
back and then into like the header files
directory right which is what this is
um and then it still doesn't work and of
course the reason why it doesn't work is
because these aren't real folders and
this is real life you know this the way
this include works and this is not real
life this is a dream this is fake and so
what you can do is you can press this
show all files mode which takes you out
of the dream world into the real world
and now you actually see relative to
this project so again this project will
have a physical file on disk and
relative to that this is what you're
seeing you're seeing the the project
kind of directory it's right here and
you can see what files are included all
of these things with this kind of uh red
like stop sign type thing whatever it is
uh those are all files that are not
included in the project so I can right
click on them and hit include if I want
and similarly I can right click on these
guys and hit exclude and suddenly this
file won't be compiled anymore and it
won't be part of like search or whatever
it'll won't be part of the solution or
will the specific project actually so
now I can see that here's my timer.cpp
in my root directory and then here are
the rest of the headers so what I can do
from here is I can just simply click and
drag it and put it into this headers
directory that's probably the easiest
way to do it because then you don't have
to like if I did it just in Windows
Explorer I then have to like it wouldn't
be able to find the file because
obviously the the visual studio project
expects it to be in a certain directory
you've moved it so you'd have to kind of
you know re reset that up
um now speaking of which obviously this
is the headers directory so we probably
wouldn't really expect it to be there
but you can see that that does fix it
now because they are in the same
directory now what if we wanted it to
work in this directory like main.cbp
well you can see what what has happened
in main.cpp we just have headers slash
and then like whatever
um so what that means is that if we
wanted it to work the same way we could
drag it back here and then just make
sure that we do headers slash timer.hp
and there we go everything works thanks
for watching I'll see you guys next time
goodbye